oh hey everyone didn't see that no
seriously I'm Ilana welcome to my let's
play of destiny I am pretty much right
where I left off in the beta if you guys
saw that video it's like two videos ago
now and I just did a thing and walked in
some tunnels and now i'm about to fight
some people so let's do it i have a face
cam as well i usually don't do that
because i don't know i find it kind of
like takes me out of the experience I
feel more pressure um and then I enjoy
games less but a lot of people requested
it so i'll just do it for like a bit of
destiny this is a pot that already
played in the beta anyway so it's not a
huge deal you're probably not gonna you
know let's play the entire game you guys
I'm sorry it's also in the reason why I
don't twitch is because I feel it kind
of ruins experiences having people watch
everything I do will make everything I
do to do with game in public it's
already my job and already talked about
it constantly and I guess I just money
you know enjoy some of it privately
sometimes you guys so that's what's up
with that
but um yeah for this finis I totally
don't mind I am a Jew warlock that's
what that means that mm-wha locked yeah
um cuz that's not about I play like any
mage class in everything I ever play I'm
weights mage claws hey the devil guy
does he look cool look at his little
helmet he actually looks like he's on
file it's the actual devil except level
2 I feel like the actual level would be
like a significantly higher level than
two but you know maybe maybe he doesn't
play destiny that much maybe the devil
has like other stuff to do I don't know
I'm not the devil this video was not in
any way sponsored by the devil I am
playing on xbox one by the way yes
that's why I like actually couldn't just
continue off where I left on the beta I
don't know if anyone could do that at
all actually usually you can't in MMOs
but I played that on peaceful I'm
playing this one on xbox one so it
wasn't an option and the real reason for
I might get it on ps4 as well but the
real reason for that was really just
because all of my main online friends
play predominantly on xbox one and i
also really can always prefer the xbox
one controller on so i appreciate these
guys respond respawn I shouldn't even be
bothering Hiram I should just be going
straight for bus guy but because I'm
talking I'm getting my ramble on and
getting distracted see I would get like
no games done if I hope if I was twitch
streaming ah because i am so no no of
you guys seem to know this I review
games full-time professionally and my
youtube channel is just like an extra
thing that I do for fun when I have the
time and I'm trying to find more time to
do it because I do really enjoy having
it as like my own personal creative
outlet but
oh god this is not going that well so
yeah it's like the most antisocial thing
reviewing two games a week because you
just don't really get to talk to people
like you wouldn't other jobs I don't
like working it off this I gotta film in
an office and there's like ten people
who work there so I like going there
fill my stuff with one person behind a
camera and I'm just talking to it and I
believe I have also worked at eb games
once a week for like six years which is
like I don't need that Germany mortal in
terms of money but the reason that I
still do walk there even though
sometimes as a month right like it was a
month recently worried and gödel because
I was like in Germany and in Sydney and
stuff because i like the social part of
it i get to actually talk to people it's
the weirdest thing but yeah who's
considering twitch streaming all of the
games that I play on pc but at the
moment my internet isn't good enough so
fellow Australians will know the NBN is
like the faster internet it's currently
being installed in my street like
literally two days ago they were dudes
putting it in the ground it just has to
be connected to houses and I feel like
that's kind of like a social way for me
to play games cuz then you know when I'm
smashing through these pc games and just
really sitting there by myself I could
maybe you know spend some of the time
when I'm not six hours in and feel like
I've learnt everything that I need you
from the experience but I'm still just
trying to get a little bit more out of
it or finish off the story for the
review and I could chat to you guys and
like have have up just a little bit of
company it's the saddest thing what no
it's connected no oh it's totally
connected so i'm using a day one and
smoke control the right now I'll just
plug it in actually ah um and every now
and then it says it's disconnected when
it's actually north because it's just
like a problem with the day one ones i
think it's not again don't lie to me
yeah these guys are totally different
least morning but I'm so close to level
threes of kids when I kill big double
guy he looks so cool man it's really
weird since I started cosplaying that
I'm always like oh man I'm gonna cosplay
the crap out of that did they kill him
yeah um Oh couldn't achieve it cool okay
um yeah I'm always like man cosplay that
but he's like a literal giant devil so
all right this way I believe thing was
this way was it no not even I don't even
I knew it wasn't this way I literally
was like it's not this way but I did it
anyway why did I do that oh we are all
good so that's like the first kind of
boss fight there is another one that I
got to in the beta that was like super
intense um that one I didn't do by
myself the first time low it's so lonely
even this i'm playing an MMO and I'm by
myself nah but really you guys can feel
free to add me if you would like my
gamertag is Charles leg which is the
same as my youtube channel in case you
don't know how to spell that lets me ja
home there you go I have 44 1064 friends
online for parental line they're
probably paying just need to be honest
book but if I was playing with them then
I couldn't be talking you guys at the
same time so okay sorry if I'm just
rambling I don't even I'm just talking I
don't even know what's going on
just looks like Star Wars so much like
Star Wars it's like Star Wars gross with
halo Death Star hello neither one either
one does when we were much more power
but that was longer until it wakes and
finds its luis i am the one who speaks
for the trouble
you must have no end of questions garlic
in its dying the traveler created the
ghosts to seek out those who can wield
its long as a weapon God and what a babe
I could tell you what the great battle
centuries ago
how the traveler was crooked
I could tell you the power well tell me
them Burt why are you waiting just tell
me come on man don't care about the
children just tell me great battle they
thinks gonna tell me the children screw
your children the darkness is coming
we will not survive uh-huh but we will
have you seen my pinecone ponytail
pineapple ponytail baby what can I do
you must push back the darkness
guardians are fighting on earth and
beyond join your ghost will go don't
know why they call them ghosts also
interesting that that I have a voice I'm
kind of not you stat characters and mm I
was actually having a voice would have
liked to have been able to pick that
that would have been nice because I
always make the same kind of character
in any kind of RPG or MMO just like some
tan dude with yellow eyes white hair
it's usually like a ponytail or super
long like a porn star what a porn star
but like one of those books you know how
they have like like thought let's just
go like thought or one of those like
weird romantic lady novels where the
dude on the front cover has really long
hair and maybe it's just like this one
that I swear that I saw when I was a kid
and was like that looks naughty with
something but I don't even but um yeah I
just try and make him like I could only
occurred to me recently that it's pretty
much always Geralt from The Witcher hmm
yeah okay go to earth um and and yeah so
I would have liked to be able to like
making super Ross P but i guess not it's
funny whenever people see the kind of
characters i make most people like wow I
can expect that I I really ashamed that
you would be some kind of off naked robe
chick like but why